welcome to the David Pakman show I'm
fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today David
is at a media and cryptocurrency event
in South Florida he will be back on
Thursday let's jump right in
obviously last few days there's been a
pretty massive news happening in the
United States first and foremost with
these indictments that were handed down
this past Friday by the special
prosecutor's office against 13
individuals three organizations all tied
to Russian campaign interference and the
spreading of propaganda via social media
and other news outlets here so just to
kind of get to the heart of it real
quick we have 13 individuals three
organizations that were indicted by
Robert Muller's office they all of these
indictments pertain to the election
interference specifically spreading of
propaganda through the United States via
Twitter Facebook they had memes entire
little organizations set up that were
running these propaganda schemes and
according to the indictment all of these
were or I shouldn't say all because it
makes sure to not say all almost all of
these things were to bash Hillary
Clinton and promote Donald Trump the
remainder that were not promoting Trump
or bashing Hillary were all pretty much
bashing people like Ted Cruz Marco Rubio
the goal was very clear they wanted
Donald Trump to be the Republican
nominee and then once he secured that
they wanted him to be President the
thing that's missing from the equation
right now is why why did they want
Donald Trump that's the big piece of all
of this that we still don't really have
an answer to did they interfere in the
election by spreading propaganda 100%
absolutely did they pack into voting
systems in the United States according
to the US government yes they did we do
not know if vote totals were changed
we do know that they successfully
penetrated voting systems in the United
States that information was revealed a
few weeks ago so again the question
still remains why why did they want
Donald Trump did they see him as
somebody they could control or was the
overall goal of this to embarrass the
United States on the global stage if
it's the latter than it's worked
we know that the rest of the world their
opinion of the United States because of
Donald Trump has plummeted tourism from
outside the United States into this
country has plummeted under Donald Trump
40,000 tourism jobs in the last year
have been lost because we just don't
have people coming over here because of
Donald Trump so if the goal was
embarrassment you know not anything
related to policy then they've already
succeeded in that because the United
States is pretty embarrassed of Donald
Trump and the rest of the world is
looking down on us if it's because they
want something out of him though that's
something that that still remains to be
determined and what exactly they could
want is another thing could it be that
they don't want sanctions against Russia
from the United States certainly a
plausible idea Donald Trump has failed
so far to implement the sanctions that
were passed with only five nay votes
recently between the House and the
Senate and Donald Trump says now we're
good we don't need those sanctions
against Russia why would we need them
and then a couple weeks after that we
get these indictments handed down